vamos a imaginar un pequeño experimento
imaginemos que nos encontramos en la
luna
y que hemos traído con nosotros dos
cosas
un bloque un ladrillo
más o menos así
y también hemos traído una pluma de
pájaro
más o menos
bueno el experimento que vamos a hacer
es y estando en la luna si yo dejo caer
estos dos objetos al mismo tiempo y
desde la misma altura cual caerá primero
al suelo
bueno ustedes en la experiencia y me
podrían decir o de lo que ustedes saben
es que si yo hago esto tiro este
ladrillo
bueno más o menos
en la tierra
pues lo que va a pasar es que va a caer
con rapidez para caer directamente al
suelo en cambio si yo tiro esta pluma
desde la tierra pues lo que va a pasar
es que va
digamos que flotando cayendo suavemente
de un lado a otro hasta que se pose en
el suelo sin duda va a tardar más tiempo
en caer la pluma que el ladrillo sin
embargo en la luna hay que tener en
cuenta que no tenemos atmósfera no hay
aire
en la luna
entonces bueno como podemos calcular
primero queremos saber cuál es la fuerza
de gravedad que existe entre el ladrillo
entre este bloque y la luna y entre la
pluma y la luna lo que vamos a hacer es
pues calcular la fuerza correspondiente
de cada uno de ellos vamos a configurar
la fuerza de la atracción gravitatoria
entre este bloque y la luna y vamos a
calcular también la fuerza atracción
gravitatoria que hay entre ésta plumita
y la luna de los vídeos pasados vimos
cuál es la fórmula de la gravitación
universal
entonces tenemos que la
fuerza de gravedad
o de atracción entre dos objetos es
igual a la constante
gravitatoria
multiplicada por la masa del primer
objeto en este caso va a ser la masa de
la luna
multiplicada por la masa del segundo
objeto que sea puede ser la pluma o el
bloque y va a estar dividida entre el
cuadrado de la distancia entre estos dos
objetos entre el centro de la luna y el
centro del bloque o el centro de la luna
y el centro de la pluma así que vamos a
calcular para cada uno de estos en
particular vamos a calcular primero para
nuestro bloque la fuerza del bloque
es igual a también todos estos elementos
los elementos que tenemos en común tanto
en la fuerza del bloque como en la
fuerza de la pluma son esto es la
constante gravitatoria la masa de la
luna y la distancia entre la el centro
de la luna y el objeto porque están
cercanos a su superficie esta distancia
es casi la misma
entonces esto lo podemos englobar con
una constante le vamos a llamar g
minúscula l de la luna
entonces la fuerza del bloque o la
fuerza atracción gravitatoria entre el
bloque va a ser esta constante o esta
aceleración de la gravedad de la luna
multiplicada por la masa
de nuestro
bloque la masa del bloque
y vamos a tener también uno que la
fuerza
de la pluma va a ser igual a exactamente
la misma constante gravitatoria en la
luna
multiplicado por la masa
de la pluma
ahora vamos a asumir que la masa y bueno
es una asunción correcta la masa de
nuestro bloque va a ser mucho mayor que
la masa de la pluma y si estos elementos
están multiplicados por exactamente el
mismo número la misma constante entonces
también podemos asumir que la fuerza
gravitacional en el bloque va a ser
mucho mayor que la fuerza
gravitacional entre la pluma y la luna
entonces bueno sí sin duda la fuerza de
atracción en el bloque va a ser mayor
que la fuerza de tracción en la pluma
pero
no esto no implica que ambos caigan en
la misma velocidad porque pues porque el
bloque tiene una masa más grande y de
las leyes de newton recordamos que
mientras más masivo sea un objeto más
lento se va a acelerar entonces la única
forma de determinar cuál de estos dos
objetos va a caer con más rapidez
rapidez es calcular la aceleración en
cada uno de ellos
bueno no está de nuestras fórmulas es
que la
fuerza
es igual a la masa por la aceleración la
fuerza es un vector la masa la
aceleración es un vector y aunque aquí
no estamos trabajando con cantidades
específicas vamos a tener la convención
de que las cantidades positivas indican
la dirección hacia abajo y las
cantidades negativas indican una
dirección hacia arriba si quiero
calcular cuál es la aceleración o
despejar la aceleración me va a quedar
que la aceleración va a ser igual si
divido todo entre la masa fuerza entre
la masa y esto entre una masa esto se
anula la aceleración me va a quedar
igual a la fuerza
entre la masa ahora si yo quiero conocer
la aceleración que se aplica al bloque
pues es igual a la fuerza del bloque
entre la masa de este bloque pero de
esta fórmula vimos qué
y nuestra
fuerza en el bloque es igual a la
gravedad
de la luna o la fuerza de atracción con
la luna y
multiplicada por la masa del bloque
entre la masa del bloque y pues estos
elementos se cancelan de manera que nos
queda que la aceleración de en el bloque
es igual a la constante a la aceleración
de la gravedad en la luna lo mismo
hacemos con la aceleración de la pluma
es igual a la fuerza de la pluma
entre la masa de la pluma en este caso
es la masa de la pluma y esto nos queda
igual que es la misma constante tenemos
vamos a la fuerza de la pluma con esta
fórmula la constante de aceleración en
la luna multiplicado por la masa de la
pluma dividido entre la masa de la pluma
y esto pues nos da igual a la misma
constante al mismo número la aceleración
en ambos objetos es exactamente la misma
así que ambos van a caer con la misma
velocidad
siempre que no exista aire entonces la
razón por la que en la tierra si hay una
diferencia de velocidad es cuando se
sueltan los objetos con diferente masa
es la resistencia al aire
aquí que si tuviéramos un bloque
en la tierra un bloque con la misma masa
que este pero si estuviera un poco más
extendido más aplanado este este nuevo
bloque con la misma masa que éste
este bloque va a caer con más una
velocidad menor ya que va a tener una
área mayor para hacer para que el aire
haga presión y oponga resistencia y es
por eso que este va a aunque tengan la
misma masa este va a caer más lento que
éste por otro lado si yo tuviera la
misma un objeto con la misma masa de la
pluma pero fuera un objeto muy compacto
muy chiquito
si lo tuviera así y lo dejará caer
caería mucho más rápido de lo que cae la
pluma es porque la pluma pues estaría un
poquito más extendido y aquí les puedo
dejar un experimento que pueden hacer en
la comodidad de su hogar o de su cuarto
donde se encuentren ustedes es que tomen
un libro
que tengan a la mano
más o menos así
y lo que hacen es pues dejar caer este
libro van a más o menos calcular cuál es
o contabilizar el tiempo que tarda en
caer a este libro
luego lo que van a hacer es tomar una
hoja de papel o alguna tarjeta algo así
que tenga en la mano y también la van a
dejar caer pues naturalmente la hoja va
a caer con una velocidad más lenta o va
a caer más despacio que el libro y ahora
lo que van a hacer es poner
esta hoja encima del libro y al poner
esto van a dejar caer el libro con la
hoja encima qué va a pasar bueno pues el
libro va a estar acá y va a caer y va a
romper toda la resistencia del aire de
manera que para la hoja ya no va a beber
aire que la esté deteniendo y esto nos
va a resultar que tanto el libro como
una hoja van a caer a la misma velocidad